oh my goodness look at you  Monique Lhullier fears I've never done  it before and I feel very liberated I  look forward to challenges and risks I  like it a lot I don't care what anybody  else thinks any secret about that you  got going on under this fabulous outfit  underwear well a lot of people don't  wear it today that's a good thing  well I'm not commando are you ready for  the fashion type that's fine oh yeah how  long did it take you to get ready Oh  hours how many dresses pant suits  whatever did you go through just this  one Wow favorite accessory earrings  dipped in stone and spanked in are  sucking it in tucking it in have  anything to stop you and stop it  first thing that you are gonna eat we  already know that answer but answer to  get that it Taco Bell and in and out and  in and up and Rosie can I go with you  yes okay  you